THE GREAT SEAN HANNITY IS RIGHT
NOW.
STAY LONG WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT WE ARE AT A TIPPING
POINT.
EVERYTHING THAT IS EXCEPTIONAL,
EVERYTHING THAT’S GREAT ABOUT
THIS COUNTRY, THE GREATEST
COUNTRY GOD GAVE MAN, OUR
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, I TELL
YOU TONIGHT IT’S IN JEOPARDY.
IN 118 DAYS, GUESS WHAT YOU’RE
THE ULTIMATE JURY AND THE
VERY WAY OF LIFE THAT WE CHERISH
IN MANY WAYS IS AT STAKE.
I WILL GIVE A LONG EXPLANATION.
EVERYTHING WE VALUE AND CHERISH
LIKE CAPITALISM, LIBERTY,
FREEDOM, THE CONSTITUTION, THE
RULE OF LAW HANGS IN THE BALANCE
BECAUSE THE MOST EXTREME RADICAL
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS ARE
PLANNING, AND THEY ARE SAYING
IT, TO FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORM
AND CHANGE AMERICA.
THEY WANT TO DISMANTLE
CAPITALISM.
THEY WANT TO ABOLISH THE POLICE.
THAT WOULD ELIMINATE ALL LAW AND
ORDER AND SAFETY AND SECURITY.
THE VERY CORRUPT, VERY FRAIL
JOE BIDEN IS CONTROLLED BY THESE
RADICALS.
HE IS WEAK.
HE IS OFTEN CONFUSED.
HE’S EASILY MANIPULATED, AND NOW
HE’S SHOWING HIS TRUE COLORS,
AND HE WILL SAY AND HE WILL DO
ANYTHING HE IS TOLD TO DO AND
SAY TO WIN AT ALL COSTS.
BREAKING TONIGHT: LOOK AT THIS.
THE BIDEN-SANDERS SOCIALIST
UNITY TASK FORCE WELL THEY JUST
RELEASED ALL BASICALLY THE
PLATFORM OF BERNIE SANDERS
AND THEY ARE PROPOSING
THE DNC PLATFORM AND IT READS
LIKE WELL A RADICAL SOCIALIST
WISH LIST.
AS PRESIDENT BIDEN, HE WOULD
GRANT CITIZENSHIP TO 11 MILLION
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
HE WOULD TURN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
INTO THE UNITED SANCTUARY STATES
OF AMERICA.
HE WOULD BLOCK I.C.E. FROM
DEPORTING EVEN CRIMINALS IN
JAIL.
BIDEN WOULD REDISTRIBUTE HER
MONEY BECAUSE OF SOMETHING WE
CALL ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
OF COURSE THE INSANE GREEN NEW
DEAL THAT HE SUPPORTS.
GET THIS.
BIDEN’S TASK FORCE ACTUALLY
COPIED BERNIE SANDERS’ PLATFORM
IN MULTIPLE SECTIONS WORD FOR
WORD.
SO IN OTHER WORDS, BIDEN ALSO
CALLS FOR UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE
THROUGH A PUBLIC OPTION.
GET THIS.
HE WOULD ELIMINATE CASH BAIL FOR
PRISONERS.
THAT’S WORKING SO WELL IN
NEW YORK, RIGHT?
ROB A BANK.
GET OUT, ROB ANOTHER.
ANARCHIST.
GET OUT, ANOTHER, GET BACK TO
THE ENTER KEY.
THAT’S MADNESS, INSANITY AND IT
DOES NOT PROTECT THE PEOPLE IN
AMERICA’S TOWNS AND CITIES.
TODAY DURING AN INTERVIEW WITH
THE FAR LEFT WEBSITE NOW THIS
NEWS, JOE FIVE NEIMAN STATED THE
POLICE, READY FOR THIS,
HAVE BECOME THE ENEMY.
BIDEN ALSO SAID HE’S ABSOLUTELY
ON BOARD WITH DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
THIS WILL CLOSELY.
>> SURPLUS MILITARY, AND FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THEY DON’T NEED
THAT.
THE LAST THING YOU NEED IS A
ARMORED HUMVEE COMING INTO A
NEIGHBORHOOD LIKE THE MILITARY
INVADING.
THEY DON’T KNOW ANYBODY.
THEY BECOME THE ENEMY.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
PROTECTING THESE PEOPLE.
>> WE CAN AGREE THAT WE CAN
REDIRECT SOME OF THE FUNDING?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE ALSO NEED
TO BE DOING IS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGING THE WAY, AND I’VE BEEN
PUSHING IT FOR YEARS, CHANGING
THE WAY WE DEAL WITH OUR PRISON
SYSTEM.
>> Sean: REMEMBER IT WAS ONLY
A MONTH AGO BIDEN REJECTED CALLS
TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
HE DID IT IN AN OP-ED AND IT
JUST ONE MONTH FOR BIDEN TO CAME
TO THE RADICALS OF HIS PARTY, IF
HE EVEN WROTE OR THE LOAN
REMEMBERS THE TOPIC OF HIS OWN
OP-ED.
INSTEAD OF MOVING TO THE CENTER
FOR THE GENERAL ELECTION, IT IS
NOW REGURGITATING THE HEART OF
TALKING POINTS FROM THE EXTREME
SOCIALISTS WHO ARE AMONG HIS TOP
ADVISORS LIKE BERNIE SANDERS
AND OCASIO-CORTEZ.
NEED MORE EVIDENCE, BECAUSE
TODAY BIDEN ALSO VOWED TO
REWRITE OUR ECONOMY.
JUST LIKE HE SAID OVER THE
WEEKEND HE WOULD TRANSFORM
AMERICA, WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
BREATHTAKING OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE GOOD PAYING UNION JOBS,
DELIVER THE PROMISE OF AMERICA
TO AMERICANS WHO’VE BEEN DENIED
IT FOR MUCH TOO LONG.
TO REWRITE OUR ECONOMY.
SO THAT PROSPERITY FLOWS NOT
JUST TO CEOs BUT TO WORKERS
WHO ACTUALLY BUILD THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: REWRITE THE ECONOMY.
SOCIALIST UTOPIA.
TRANSFORM AMERICA.
POLICE ARE THE ENEMY.
DEFUND THE POLICE.
LET ME TRANSLATE THIS FOR YOU:
BIDEN IS TALKING ABOUT
SOCIALISM, JUST LIKE BERNIE,
JUST LIKE ELIZABETH WARREN,
PROBABLY EVEN WORSE THAN JUST
LIKE CONGRESSWOMAN
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
NOW WE KNOW WHAT HE MEANT WHEN
HE SAID TO TRANSFORM AMERICA.
THAT WILL BE RAISING YOUR TAXES.
IT WILL BE CONFISCATION OF
WEALTH.
THAT WILL BE CONTROL OF THE
MEANS OF PRODUCTION WHEREVER
POSSIBLE AND THE ELIMINATION OF
THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE WORLD
ECONOMY, OIL AND GAS, AND THIS
IS NOW THE MISSION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC EXTREME SOCIALIST
PARTY.
THIS IS WHAT THEY WANT.
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE SAYING
THEY ARE GOING TO DO.
THAT IS THE PROPOSAL THE
BIDEN-BERNIE UNITY SOCIALIST
TASK FORCE AND BIDEN WHO RARELY
LEAVES HIS OWN HOUSE, SEEMINGLY
ALWAYS IN THE STATE OF
CONFUSION, WELL HE’S A PERFECT
CANDIDATE FOR THESE RADICALS
BECAUSE THEY WILL CONTROL HIM
OBVIOUSLY.
BIDEN COULDN’T EVEN REMEMBER
WHAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT WHILE
EVEN APPARENTLY READING FROM THE
TELEPROMPTER.
OH, THIS IS TAKING ME TOO LONG.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> I BELIEVE THIS WITH EVERY
FIBER IN MY BEING.
WHAT I PROPOSE IS...
IT CAN BE DONE.
I THINK WE ARE IN A POSITION TO
REALLY MAKE IT HAPPEN.
MY TEAM AND YOUR TEAM ARE
ALREADY WORKING CLOSELY TOGETHER
TO LIGHT UP THE PATH FORWARD
HERE.
CRITICAL LAWS TO STRENGTHEN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
ON POLITICS LIKE PREVAILING.
LOOK, YES, I’M -- I’M TAKING TOO
MUCH TIME.
>> Sean: I PROPOSE THAT -- I
PROPOSE.
THIS IS TAKING TOO LONG.
DO I HAVE TO KEEP EXPLAINING
SOMETHING THAT I DON’T EVEN KNOW
WHAT IT IS?
WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT THAT ALL MEN AND
WOMEN ARE CREATED EQUAL BY THE
THING, YOU KNOW.
THE THING.
GOD, THE CREATOR OF EVERYTHING.
THAT’S BRUTAL.
THAT’S ACTUALLY HARD TO WATCH.
DOES THIS MAN HAVE THE STRENGTH,
THE STAMINA, THE MENTAL ACUITY
TO TAKE ON WHAT IS THE TOUGHEST
JOB BY FAR IN THE WORLD?
THE ANSWER TO ME IS OBVIOUSLY
NO.
FRANKLY IT’S NO TO ANYBODY WITH
CLEAR EYES THAT CAN SEE.
THE MEDIA WANTS LITERALLY ASKED
THOSE VERY QUESTIONS OF
RONALD REAGAN IN 1984.
ARE THEY GOING TO ASK THE SAME
TO BIDEN?
NO I DON’T THINK SO BECAUSE THE
MOB AND THE MEDIA IS TREATING
BIDEN LIKE A FRAGILE PRECIOUS
LITTLE ARTIFACT.
NEW YORK TOILET PAPER TIMES
ACTUALLY CALLING FOR BIDEN,
MARK LEVIN HAS BEEN SAYING IT.
RUSSIA HAS BEEN SAYING THIS.
I’VE BEEN SAYING IT.
NOT TO DEBATE PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE KNOW WHO WILL BE IN CHARGE IF
BIDEN WINS IN NOVEMBER.
COMBINED EXPERIENCE.
BIDEN, PELOSI, SCHUMER, 125
YEARS IN THE SWAMP IN D.C.
TRUMP LESS THAN FOUR.
THEY ARE FULLY CONTROLLED BY
THEIR RADICAL BASE.
SOCIALIST WILL CONTROL THE
MESSAGING.
THEY WILL CONTROL THE PLATFORM.
THEY WILL CONTROL THE STRATEGY.
THEY WILL CONTROL THE IDEAS.
THEY WILL TRY TO LITERALLY
TRANSFORM AMERICA.
IF WE BECOME THAT SOCIALIST
UTOPIA, 94 TRILLION NEW GREEN
DEAL, 52 TRILLION MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
GUESS WHAT.
THOSE WILL ALL BE BROKEN
PROMISES AND EVERYTHING IS FREE
AND NO OIL AND GAS TO PRODUCE
ANYTHING.
WE SEE THIS ALREADY HAPPENING IN
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
THE SQUAD HAS INTRODUCED A BILL
TO DEFUND THE POLICE AND BY THE
WAY HANDOUT REPARATIONS.
IN A PRESS CONFERENCE YESTERDAY,
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR SAID THAT HER
GOAL WAS TO DISMANTLE THE
UNITED STATES.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> WE MUST RECOGNIZE THAT THE
SYSTEMS OF OPPRESSION ARE
LINKED.
AS LONG AS OUR ECONOMY AND
POLITICAL SYSTEMS PRIORITIZE
PROFIT WITHOUT CONSIDERING WHO
IS PROFITING, WHO IS BEING SHUT
OUT.
WE WILL PERPETUATE THIS
INEQUALITY.
SO WE CANNOT STOP AT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE MUST BEGIN THE WORK OF
DISMANTLING THE WHOLE SYSTEM OF
OPPRESSION.
>> Sean: SHE’S NOT THE ONLY
ELECTED OFFICIAL ON THE LEFT
OPENLY CALLING FOR AMERICA TO BE
DESTROYED.
LISTEN TO THIS SCARY MESSAGE
FROM ONE OF SEATTLE’S
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE COMING FROM THIS
DEEPLY OPPRESSIVE RACIST SEXIST
VIOLENT UTTERLY BANKRUPT SYSTEM
OF CAPITALISM, THIS POLICE STATE
STATE.
WE CANNOT AND WILL NOT STOP
UNTIL WE OVERTHROW IT AND
REPLACE IT WITH A WORLD BASED
INSTEAD ON SOLIDARITY, GENUINE
DEMOCRACY, AND EQUALITY.
A SOCIALIST WORLD.
>> Sean: THERE IS NO MIDDLE
GROUND.
THE NEW RADICAL DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY.
THEY WILL DESTABILIZE NOT ONLY
THIS COUNTRY BUT THE ENTIRE
WORLD ALONG WITH IT.
ABOLISHING THE POLICE, YOU KNOW
THE ONES THAT PROTECT GRANDMA,
GRANDPA MOM AND DAD AND LET SEE
YOUNG MOMS THAT HAVE KIDS AT
HOME, MAYBE THE FATHER IS
WORKING.
THEN THEY WILL SEE CONTROL OVER
YOUR PROPERTY, MONEY, BUSINESS
ALL IN THE NAME OF FAIRNESS AND
REDISTRIBUTION AND BY THE WAY TO
CREATE THEIR PERFECT UTOPIA.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS EVERYWHERE
SOCIALISM OR WHATEVER FORM IT’S
BEEN TRIED HAS ALSO FAILED.
DON’T FALL FOR THESE EMPTY
PROMISES OF EVERYTHING IS FREE
BECAUSE THERE’S SOMETHING CALLED
SIMPLE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL MATH
AND MAYBE JOE COULD PUT ASIDE
HIS ABACUS AND ACTUALLY
CALCULATOR OUT AND
FIGURE OUT THAT LET ME BE CLEAR,
SOCIALISM ALWAYS WILL END IN
MISERY AND DESPAIR, ALWAYS AND